what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into a Hal Jordan and
the Green Lantern Corps the quest for
hope the funny thing about this is that
I accidentally deleted this recording
like I had this already done and
everything and then accident deleted it
and I was like no because I tried all my
recovery software in order to get it
back and I couldn't find it that was
like oh my god so I've got to go back
and rerecord it but the cool thing is
that this is kind of par for the course
like I usually record audios a couple of
times to make sure that I get all the
points across you know that I want to
make but for those of you guys who are
new to the Green Lantern landscape the
way that DC rebirth has done Green
Lantern is in two different ways
we have Green Lantern's rebirth which is
basically the new fans guide to Green
Lantern's you literally learn about the
Green Lantern mythos as as Simon Baz and
Jessica Cruz learn about it then there's
Hal Jordan and the Green Lantern Court
and that's more for established things
all it really did when greenlit I guess
when Hal Jordan and the Green Lantern
Corps rebirth kicked off is it continued
a lot of the stories that had just kind
of had dangling plot threads at the end
of geoff johns run going into robert
vendetta's run and so that was a goal to
basically wrap those things up and so
what happened is Robert VIN did he began
the process of writing his own stories
of basically saying here's everything
that I'm creating for the very first
time and it's really really cool because
it comes together almost seamlessly you
could just follow the entire story
because again Green Lantern as it stands
right now is this massive ten years long
worth of just events it's just this
massive cosmology but the idea here is
that this initially picks up with a guy
named space cabbie now the funny thing
about this is its space cabbie is not
news space cabbies been around for a
long time but this fits directly in line
with the nature of DC rebirth which is
to say that we're basically talking
about this point where DC is grabbing
characters that had been around for a
very long time whether they were obscure
whether they were really popular and
basically either updating them or
keeping them the same if they were that
familiar for example Wally West the
classic flash came back and he's
basically the same when it comes to a
character like space cabby he's about as
obscure as it gets this guy first popped
up back in 1954 with mystery and space
number 21 I think it was I want to say
he was an auto bender creation but I'm
not gonna swear to that but the idea was
that space cabby is exactly what he
sounds like he's a guy that ferries
people across the universe now DC kind
of delves into these things periodically
and it's really just designed to kind
bolster the cosmic landscape of DC
Comics that was the original purpose of
space cabbie and that's the purpose he
serves now for the most part whenever it
comes to the cosmos Green Lantern is
about as extensive as it gets we don't
really see a whole lot of other stories
out there that deal with like the cosmic
landscape of DC didn't like Marvel
Marvel you'll read guardians of the
galaxy you'll read Captain Marvel
depending on who's riding it you can
read Thanos you'll get this huge
well-rounded space you know exploration
and in fact the spacefaring escapades of
the various characters that exist out
there are usually done just as much as
the earth-based events so you're just as
likely to see a story of Captain America
fighting the Red Skull as you are to see
Thanos trying you know fighting against
Galactus and like overpowering him which
he did and it was an amazing story but
the idea here is that space cabby was a
guy who's basically done everything I
mean he's been a soldier of fortune he's
just been a ferryman he's done all kinds
of stuff he lends his abilities to the
highest bidder the reason why he's in
this story is because this ties in to
the existing events that are going on in
Hal Jordan and the Green Lantern Corps
if you're just now joining the events
what effectively had happened is that we
had basically Sinestro and Hal Jordan
fighting one another for what was
believed to be the last time that was
the idea they've been enemies for so
long bc rebirth was designed to kind of
make a return to familiarity but also
begin moving things in a different
direction and the whole Sinestro as a
backdrop a villain - Hal Jordan had been
going on for decades and decades and
decades and so it made sense a DC would
come along and say let's go ahead and
back off and let's try something new and
so in the very first story arc of Hal
Jordan and the Green Lantern Corps
called sinestro's law Hal Jordan and
Sinestro fought and they were both
basically killed now the idea is that
following the death of Sinestro his
daughter cirrhotic took up his mantle
now if you're following our Green
Lantern videos on Sunday which is when
we covered all the classic Green Lantern
stuff that leads into DC rebirth what we
know is it's ironic as the daughter of
Sinestro was originally a member of the
Green Lantern Corps the issue is that
eventually she became a member of the
Sinestro Corps but during Hal Jordan the
Green Lantern rebirth with the death of
Sinestro she took up her father's mantle
but instead of being a bad guy what she
did is she worked directly alongside Jon
Stewart and brought the Green Lantern's
and the Sinestro Corps together now with
regards to the Green Lantern's
themselves this again fits in to a lot
of the stuff that was leading in to DC
rebirth what had happened is
there was basically a story called edge
of oblivion I think it was and it was
essentially the Green Lantern's just
kind of being catapulted or at least
what was left to the Green Lantern's
being catapulted all the way back to the
very beginning of the universe and the
result was that in the present day there
were no Green Lantern's the result was
that Sinestro saw as his chance to
basically take the Sinestro Corps have
it masquerade as a peacekeeping force
off of the purpose of basically building
on people believing in them the idea was
that once people who looked to the
Sinestro Corps as their protectors
Sinestro would betray them he would
instill fear and then conquer the
universe but all that basically came to
a head during Hal Jordan the Green
Lantern Corps rebirth with sinestro's
law and so again what this means is that
at this point in the story we basically
have a strange situation you have
basically a lot of the members of the
Sinestro Corps who despise the Green
Lantern's and you've got a lot of
members of the Green Lantern's who
despise the Sinestro Corps because
they've been fighting for so long
remember when the Sinestro Corps first
showed up and again I have Sinestro
Corps war down in the description you're
welcome to check it out when the
Sinestro Corps first popped up they
started slaughtering Green Lantern's
everywhere they saw them it was an
absolute bloodbath it wasn't until they
got to the point where it looked like
Sinestro was going to win that the
guardians of the universe adjusted the
the laws of the Rings allowing Green
Lantern's to kill members of the
Sinestro Corps that turned the tide and
the Green Lantern's ended up winning the
war or at least they basically defeated
the Sinestro Corps but the idea is that
following the defeat of Sinestro and all
this kind of stuff that's going on right
now what this basically means is that
the Green Lantern's and the Sinestro
Corps have a very tenuous relationship
to say the least but in that first story
arc with the death of Hal Jordan what we
found out was a Kyle Rayner as the white
Lantern had essentially resurrected him
now remember as the white lantern Kyle
Rayner has mastery over all the rings he
can do anything I mean he's basically
God in DC's universe and that's
something that I want you to keep in
mind for a second because once we get to
the end of this video it's really gonna
showcase just how powerful dr. Manhattan
is but the idea here is that with Hal
Jordan having died because he was kind
of a rallying point for the Green
Lantern's what this meant was that the
Guardians of the Universe needed him or
at least what was left of the Guardians
ganthet and sayd they needed him alive
and so getting with Kyle Rayner having
him reach into the afterlife and bring
Hal Jordan back while Hal Jordan was
there among the dead he had spoke with
his predecessor a dancer the guy who had
given Hal Jordan
very first ring a Navin swear statement
was pretty cryptic to say the least but
he had simply just said go find hope now
the initial indication here was that it
meant go find the blue lanterns and so
what ends up happening is how a Hal
Jordan alongside Kyle Rayner basically
raced off to a place called the misery
Mound now the misery mound is basically
just kind of a mountain
you know occupied by all these creatures
and so on that exists for the purpose of
just stripping people of their desire
for hope and that's the necessity that's
the nature of the misery Mound when it
comes to the blue lanterns of course I
imagine a lot of this might be new to
people who are stumbling across this but
when it comes to the blue lanterns they
are a lantern court predicated on hope
and they're probably the most powerful
just because hope is the only thing that
people can have that will allow them to
do anything else with people like
Atrocitus for example Atrocitus as the
head of the Red Lantern Corps feels
nothing but rage but his rage is
predicated on the hope that he can
succeed in destroying all the other
Lantern cores in existence so again
everything boils down to hope and that's
the reason why it is the blue lanterns
are so powerful but when the Lantern
cores were created by geoff johns back
when he was doing his massive run every
Lantern core had to have a caveat which
is to say they had to have a weakness
and so the idea is that with the blue
lanterns they function at their absolute
peak when they're accompanied by a Green
Lantern and that's why this is important
is because state Walker as the last
remaining Blue Lantern is powerful in
his own right but his power is bolstered
and complemented by the Green Lantern's
and so with the arrival of Hal Jordan
alongside Kyle Rayner what this does is
it basically begins the process of
beefing up the abilities of the Blue
Lantern Corps beefing up the abilities
of Saint Walker the problem with this is
that when it comes to blue lanterns and
the reason why this misery mound is
really happening is because blue
lanterns have to constantly feel hope
that brings us into the idea of the blue
lanterns basically falling of being
eradicated there was a story that was
written and I cannot remember what it
was called for the life of me but it
dealt with a villain named relic and
relic was a guy who had come from a
previous universe where the emotional
spectrum have basically run rampant and
then eventually just kind of went away
and the result was that all life in the
universe if I remember correctly had
basically gone the result of this is
that he had shown up in the main DC
Universe for the purpose of
exterminating all the lantern course
keeping their power from running a
and then forcing the same result of his
universe the first Lantern Corps that he
targeted were the blue lanterns now the
blue lanterns were the easiest to target
because despite how powerful they were
if at any point a Blue Lantern does not
feel hope their ring will take off the
ring will leave them hanging and they'll
just be as powerless as anybody else
will be tied them if their ring leaves
them while they're in the depths of
space and they can't breathe so because
of that during this whole skirmish with
the blue lanterns were basically just
falling left and right st. Walker was
the last guy left ultimately saved
Walker lost connection with his Blue
Lantern ring and the blue lanterns were
no more now eventually he regained it
and what that did is it went into DC
rebirth the problem was that when DC
rebirth first kicked off we didn't know
what Saint Walker was doing we had no
idea where he was or what was going on
there was no information on his
character what this reveals is that he's
basically been off fighting the misery
mound and the misery mound serves a
purpose of trying to relinquish people
of their hope of trying to exterminate
all hope in their entirety now again
because this is pretty new in relation
to DC rebirth which is to say we're
about a year and a half two years out
from DC rebirth in terms of the lead-up
the main event itself all that kind of
good stuff a lot of folks are still
jumping into caldron of the Green
Lantern Corps for the very first time
and so because of this we're basically
picking up into the idea of people
learning about all this for the first
time and that's why this misery mound is
here to basically give people who are
reading for the first time an
understanding of what the blue lanterns
are about now the idea here is that with
Hal Jordan and with Kyle Rayner
basically being subdued by the misery
Mound it shows us what it does and again
the misery mound exists for the purpose
of just taking people's - hope away but
it's not like an energy thing right like
it's not like it attaches these tendrils
assists now I'm stripping you of your
hope instead it's very much similar to
like the black mercy plants for example
you attach the black mercy plant to a
person and they just see their perfect
dreams forever and ever and ever and
they're basically just held prisoner
until they die with regards to this a
person is basically forced to see the
one thing that they love the most the
one thing they would love to see happen
and then that beautiful future is
transformed into a nightmare in the case
of Hal Jordan he has a family he has
children he has Carol Ferris set aside
and then suddenly that shifts into a
nightmare
where he goes back to being a villain
and just everybody around him dies when
it comes to Kyle Rayner he's basically
the white lantern he's effectively DC's
space Jesus because of that he sees
himself as
of all life as a representation of all
life being a protector in the most
definitive statement the problem with
this is his nightmare is falling down
and becoming parallax becoming a villain
now remember what these characters
they've experienced this kind of thing
before Kyle Rayner did become parallax
the living embodiment of fear during
Sinestro Corps war Hal Jordan has lost
almost everything he cared about in some
form or fashion friends family loved
ones a whole nine yards and so the idea
is that with them basically experiencing
this horrible nightmare Saint Walker as
a Blue Lantern begins to empower them
with hope and in doing so allows them to
basically break free of the misery
mounds so again this misery man is
pretty powerful but it's really the
emotional connection that exists between
these three lanterns that makes them
able to beat the misery mound in the
first place now following this it goes
into a whole explanation of hey the
guardians of the universe at me out here
in order to basically make sure that I
could find hope that kind of a thing
because River ganthet and sayd as the
guardians of the universe were the ones
who made the Blue Lantern race in the
first place now their goal in terms of
why it is that Hal Jordan came and why
it is a kyle rayner came again hits back
to the nature of the blue lantern rings
Blue Lantern rings can only function at
the peak if they're accompanied by a
Green Lantern ring and so having Hal
Jordan there was one because of the fact
that he's the one that got the message
from heaven sewer but - because if Saint
Walker is in danger his Lantern ring
will bolster the power of st. Walker's
ring now Kyle Rayner being there is
because as the guy who's basically the
nature of life itself he can resurrect
the dead the goal of the guardians of
the universe the goal of ganthet and
Satan is to basically use a Kyle Rayner
as the white lantern to reach in and
grab the life essences of those blue
lanterns who perished from Saint Walker
and resurrect them from the dead using
Saint Walker as kind of an anchor to do
so to go into the afterlife to grab
those guys say hey you have to come back
and so that's the whole nature of this
that's the whole purpose of this entire
story in terms of those characters now
what is up happening here is that once
this really begins to go into effect we
get a massive glimpse of what it is that
dr. Manhattan can do now it's not
explicitly stated but we're effectively
told that's the case when it comes to
Kyle Rayner and when it comes to him
speaking with the Guardians once they
began the process of basically using
Kyle to try to reach into the afterlife
and grab these blue lanterns
should have been seamless no one to st.
Walker's mind drive the connections to
the blue lanterns speak with them
whatever is it he had do and then bring
them back the problem with this is that
someone gets in his way someone stops
Kyle Rayner from being able to do this
we know that just because of the fact
that the entire event come crashing down
now again the biggest indication were
given here is that we run into st.
Walker's simply saying I felt a presence
an intruder that was barring our paths
now when it comes to the white lantern
in DC Comics there are characters that
can overpower him I mean like the
presence for example probably the
spectre you know there's a few
characters out there that could
overpower the white lantern because
they're just that powerful we have no
reason to believe that the presence the
spectre the Phantom Stranger held even
imperiex in the 1990s we have no reason
to believe that any of those characters
have a reason to bar that half of white
lantern kyle rayner resurrecting the
blue lanterns resurrecting hope the idea
here is that dr. Manhattan is the one
that's keeping that from happening and
it all fits into the very notion of the
blue lanterns themselves the blue
lanterns embody hope the blue lanterns
are insanely powerful the other half of
this is that this sees the destruction
of the white Lantern ring Kyle Rayner is
no longer the white Lantern and there
are no white lanterns anymore that's the
important thing about this that's the
biggest takeaway from this and the
reason why is because let's say for
example that Justice League versus
Watchmen unfolds and we've got dr.
Manhattan fighting the Justice League
there's been time so really I think it
was during blackest night or brightest
day there was a point where the entire
Justice League became white lanterns
they were all as powerful as Kyle Rayner
the biggest issue this represents is
that if dr. Manhattan shows up and dr.
Manhattan had to fight all these white
lanterns he would be epic and it would
be cool
but most people would look at that and
say sure he could probably defeat Kyle
Rayner but no way he could defeat like
eight white lanterns that's ridiculous
and so why even go down that route why
not just wipe out the white lanterns in
their entirety that way you don't have
to worry about this the other half is
that the white lantern story arc of Kyle
Rayner had basically reached his end
kaena becoming the white Lantern was
kind of this prescind out of his whole
story going all the way back to the mid
1990s with
Twilight Hal Jordan becoming a bad guy
destroying all the Green Lantern's
ganthet showing up to kyle rayner and
saying you are the last of the lanterns
here's a ring use it wisely all that led
to Kyle Rayner becoming a white lantern
to this moment when he goes back to
being who he was before because with the
white Lantern ring being an amalgamation
of all these other Lantern rings one is
up happening is they all basically
dispersed the white Lantern ring
shatters the other emotions form into
their own rings they dispersed across
the universe and they start looking for
new house the only exception to that is
the Green Lantern ring which rebonds
itself to Kyle Rayner setting him back
to who he was before before all of this
stuff you know with the white Lantern
ring all kicked out and so the idea
seems to be that he's kind of going back
to the era of ayan but at the very least
Carl Reiner's character is going back to
the beginning is kind of resetting
everything back to zero to a degree now
it's not a reboot or anything like that
we'll probably see the white lanterns
return that's the indication here dr.
Manhattan is more powerful than the
white lanterns that's the implication
but I'm kind of curious what you guys
think you guys that's true do you think
dr. Manhattan is more powerful than a
white lantern
I'm just kind of curious about that but
with that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the robb for if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you